un buffet sucré salé pour dire merci aux
donneurs des victuailles préparé par le
traiteur versailles et gaulupeau une
idée de la table ronde française de
versailles un club composé d'hommes pour
la première édition on a contacté le fs
on leur a proposé notre projet ils ont
tout de suite accroché
en plus ils ont besoin de ce type
d'événement pour avoir constamment des
poches de sang à disposition et les
week-ends comme aujourd'hui week-end de
pâques sont des week-ends assez creux
pour eux un don dure environ une heure
dès 10 heures ce samedi les yvelinois
répondait présent j'ai de commencer à
donner dans le cadre de l'art mais
j'étais militaire vent et donc bon c'est
aussi une facilité de logistique que
j'ai de donner tous les mois je pense
que tout le monde est susceptible d'en
avoir besoin un jour en ce moment il ya
une campagne qui nous dit que donner son
sang c'est sauver 3 vies
donc je trouve ça comme un incitateur
pour cette deuxième édition de don du
sang gastronomes une quarantaine de
donneurs se sont donné rendez vous
l'établissement français possède
actuellement 14 sites fixes en
ile-de-france est organisée près de 3000
collectes mobiles par an